hello and welcome to this video playing
the Blitz king and ya know shiki
openings play the classical Queens
gambit here maybe we should buy five I
should've played has a bit more
interesting okay no no big deal yo
Bishop f5 I guess maybe I can go queen
bee three and kind of mean queen bee
sixes not a move that I can easily play
okay not interested in a anything
special here just place normal moves Oh
wants to go quick g5 you could be 6 a-6
okay yeah well he's basically claiming
that I'm not threatening on b2 which is
kind of true
I may could have gone Queen a 6s was as
I had to yeah planned earlier but I
couldn't really figure out if it was any
good centralizing shouldn't be bad yeah
that's a very interesting kind of
position there with f4 maybe i'm just in
back shaver against this huge space but
we shouldn't forget that his king is
also not entirely saves on playing this
quickly trying to open up lines against
the skin
hmm yeah I guess otherwise I'm just yeah
pushed back too much pawn takes Knight
f6 is interesting i'll probably get at
five back why can't I can play book of
eight by the way that that's more
interesting actually Teague's will give
aid for direct night x f5 a bit
surprised that you take so much here
maybe maybe he wants to play on the
queenside directly but k well pawn takes
Queen takes yeah anyway
hmm it's that bad for me I mean with
this King isn't this interesting so
wants to play some kind of discovered a
check on me I guess night night no
Knight f6 is no good so let's bring the
Queen over for Knight f6 Knight g4 wife
possible I could have taken on g6 but
that that didn't have a threat I mean
and I want oh that's a pretty brutal
93 is also coming into consideration
yeah and their way I have their 969 tEEX
I wanted to check with the look on f4
but now I recognize that this is
probably not working at all here I can
take only four right check that is
spinning for me that is a line that I
had calculated correctly I think okay so
let's not be can go naija five year as
well exactly and he has no good square
to go to 2f to his turn a pin g2s check
on d5 and there's no other moves
white resins tough game I think probably
that wasn't a particularly great
position at her store then it got very
unclear so here I feel that white should
should have an advantage yeah maybe with
normal use so this white white is
probably better something he made that
move so 97 and yeah just something like
that is kind of normal it's probably
between between equal and a slight edge
to white yeah something like that juster
yeah I don't want to play a second game
here just set that it's slightly better
phone say better foam and yeah this is
it's a tricky it's a tricky position but
his King is always exposed but he's got
that big space engine just wants to grab
the porn it wouldn't be fought now I
think this is this is this is okay
getting this back and making sure that
our open lines against this King and
yeah I can the computer is typically
merciless and just says I'm flat out
winning yeah this move again I mean you
can of course defend better than you did
and but that's already too late I think
that's he's making the Moose now I think
I'm okay it's a pawn and he has no no
substantial attack the engine is just
some plus two so I don't know it's
probably not much there I'm just winning
him now everyone don't want to unless I
this is just a winner and around here I
think it's pretty pretty useless I
wonder if 93 was really a good move I
actually doubted and been taking a
certainly good for me but I thought then
add this this flesh that this is good
yeah but it isn't of course because I'm
in a pin I mean okay this is a still
interesting position but I'm sorry and
this track is probably what I would have
played then green takes something
something like this and this isn't
listen this isn't clear at all I
computer give us a cool idea this one if
I take it f five wins the Queen check
you three check can you want what a
wacky line that's really funny okay yeah
thanks for watching